what's are you doing for me well a lot
first it opens up opportunities
you're free to live work and travel
across 27 countries in the world's
biggest single Market
the EU fights for fairness acting to
tackle the energy crisis and ensure
adequate minimum wages it protects us as
Citizens and consumers making sure our
food is safe our air is clean and our
online environment secure
it also guarantees our rights promoting
gender equality and work-life balance
improving conditions for parents carers
and women in the workplace
listen the EU is a global power
supporting democracy protecting the
environment securing trade deals
promoting peace progress and security
it's all that and much more